everyone obviously knows that russia has
invaded ukraine and the people on the
ground the ukrainians they're struggling
there's people who are trying to leave
the country there's people who's trying
to get their money out of the banks well
yesterday ftx the multi-billion dollar
cryptocurrency exchange they decided to
give every single ukrainian user anyone
that has an ftx account that is in
ukraine twenty five dollars this is
pretty incredible what we have here is
sam bakeman free the ceo saying we just
gave 25 to each ukrainian on ftx do what
you gotta do and ultimately this is
exactly what bitcoin and cryptocurrency
industry is all about people trying to
help people we know that ukrainian folks
are going through a really tough time
and a little bit of money may actually
be pretty material right now so to watch
ftx do this is pretty cool now of course
it's not just because 25 may be helpful
what we've seen in the ukrainian banks
is that they're limiting all sorts of
transactions we've got here this tweet
that i pulled a quote from that said
following the declaration of martial law
in ukraine the central bank suspended
the country's currency market stopped
the circulation of all securities
limited cash withdrawals and halted the
use of electronic currency and digital
wallets obviously bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are one potential
solution for this problem bitcoin is
decentralized digital currency and of
course stable coins are popular around
the world and various other assets are
being adopted as well and so ultimately
what we are watching is that in the time
of need
some ukrainians are turning to crypto
and it's pretty cool to see ftx helping
to accelerate that